there's a quote that uh that the the
that when you're starting a business the
years are short and the days are long
and that's how it's been for for me you
know this decade's gone by so quick now
there's been a lot of grind in there but
it goes by it goes by fast you know and
I usually tell folks there are no
overnight successes it's going to take
you five to seven years to figure
something out so just just get your best
idea and then work keep working on it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders I
am really excited to be joined today by
Brian Clayton the CEO and co-founder of
greenpal an online Marketplace that
connects homeowners with local Lawn Care
Professionals greenpal has been called
The Uber for lawn care by Entrepreneur
magazine and has over 200 000 active
users completing thousands of
transactions per day
all right let us do it Brian Clayton
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for being here how are you
Michael's great to be on the show it's
great to thank you for having me
thank you very very much for being here
uh Brian all the way from Nashville
Tennessee uh I just love the
intersection of Technology with the
world and the way the different people
grow up and I think this speaks also to
your to your journey as well from a
growing up and taking part in certain
actions and then and then seeing the
mobile development world and software in
general and seeing how that integrates
to take your own experience and to
leverage that into that of of so many
other people and connecting you know
through a Marketplace uh for a real for
a real need I just love that and so this
is going to be a fun episode for me to
sit back and hear an entrepreneurial
Journey from you know a real
entrepreneurial Journey so Brian first
of all tell me a little bit about you
know what you're doing today and and
then what I really want to do is I want
to go back all the way to the beginning
and hear how this whole thing unfolded
yeah sounds great so my name is Brian
Clayton I'm CEO and co-founder of a
company called greenpal greenpal is a
mobile app that works like doordash or
instacart or even Uber but for lawn
maintenance so if you rent a home or own
a home you need to get somebody to cut
your yard rather than calling around on
Facebook or Craigslist or something like
that you just download green power pop
your address in you'll get four or five
quotes from lawn care services in your
neighborhood and you can hire them right
through the app and pay them right
through the app and after the mowing
goes well you just set it and forget it
and and move on to other things green
pal is a 10-year overnight success my
co-founders and I have been at this
thing for a decade and now we're
Nationwide in the United States around
300 000 people using the app to get
their lawn maintenance done around 33
000 contractors use it to run their lawn
mowing business so it started off really
slow and and humble but now we uh we
have a strong Nationwide Network
three hundred thousand ten year
overnight success or we're gonna we're
gonna have to unpack it as much as we
can in in 20 short minutes take take me
to the beginning lawn mowing
um
how how does it start for you where does
your own upbringing fit into this yeah
so I I didn't start off as a tech
entrepreneur I actually started off as a
lawn guy I I started mowing grass in
high school as a way to make extra cash
and stuck with my little lawn mowing
business all through high school all
through college and when I graduated
college I had to make a decision was I
going to go into the job market or stick
with this little lawn care business that
I had and I didn't really want to be a
long guy my whole life but I thought hey
maybe business ownership could be my
Lane maybe it could be the thing that
that I could you know do with my life
and so I made a little business plan
with what I learned in business school
and over a 15-year period of time ended
up building one of the larger
landscaping companies in the state of
Tennessee where I live uh getting that
business so around 150 employees over 10
million a year in revenue and uh and
then in 2013 that business was acquired
by a national company and so growing it
from just being a push mower to me and
90 some mod trucks going out every day I
learned how to get a business going I
learned a lot about the industry and
then when I sold that company I I
thought well what am I going to do with
my life now because something was
missing I didn't have a project a
mission I didn't have didn't have a
company to put my energy into and I
thought well somebody's going to build
an app to make it easy to get this
service done might as well be me and uh
it was naivete as an asset I didn't
really understand how challenging it was
going to be but just got in there
recruited two co-founders and started
working on it
incredible and so tell me going back to
that first business some of those
business lessons you've learned about
yourself but it sounds like you're
you're very motivated and intentional
about the way that you're experiencing
these Endeavors it's not just a not just
money Fame and ego this is about you
know building something that you that's
meaningful to you and and having
insignificant stake in it what were
things that you've learned about
yourself about about the business World
from your first experience yeah we're
really uh both experiences
um are similar in the way that uh you
look back and it's almost like levels of
a video game and you just work one level
at a time and you don't get bent out of
shape about you know levels eight nine
or ten you don't worry about Bowser when
you're on levels one two or three and
that's how the first business was and
that's how this my second Company Green
palette is and as you are going through
these levels you as the founder you as
entrepreneur are leveling up you are
getting new skills you're growing you're
evolving it's one of the funnest things
about starting a business is that if
you're doing it right every two or three
years you should evolve in a talk into a
totally different person and uh that's
how it's been for me for the last 22
years you know it's like like we're not
taught things like management we're not
taught how to be decent leaders we're
not taught how to do bookkeeping we're
not taught how to do uh strategic
analysis we're not taught how to do how
to run a business and you have to really
learn these things as you go in order to
get from one level to the next and
that's one of the cool things looking
back 22 years that I've I've observed is
that it's caused me to do things in life
that I never would have done and become
somebody who I never would have been
that's a really interesting way of
putting it it's caused me to become a
person I never perhaps would have been
exactly
how do you feel that it transcends into
life outside of the business you know
the the person that it forces you to
become yeah a lot a lot a lot of Virtues
that you acquire starting a business
from scratch uh humility well one of the
most humbling things you can do is start
a business because you realize really
quick that nobody cares about it uh that
the only the only uh value you have is
solving a problem for a customer and
however much attention you want to
Garner for yourself it doesn't matter so
long as as what is the value proposition
of business and is it and is it making
people's lives better and so that's
really a an exercise and it's not about
me it's about my customers it's about my
stakeholders it's about it's about
people that depend on the business and
so that's a that's a really good lesson
to learn in life is is humility and and
parting a business from scratch will
definitely give you that lesson uh and
then the other thing is is just how to
become a decent leader and and
Leadership really is servitude
leadership is is serving others it's
helping others get to where they're
trying to to go and maybe the business
is the vehicle to do that and uh
leadership you know can can go can spill
into all other sorts of parts of life
whether it be being a parent or being a
good member of a community or or
volunteering you know like my business I
am my business and and and those virtues
definitely affect other parts of my life
um and I'm grateful for that you know
because if I just worked a regular job
somewhere I don't think I would have
gotten that exposure to learning those
skills
right
only about green pal and um a little bit
about what you what what you had to
study in the marketplace of
of your business of the consumer
behavior of the of the Freelancers or
the the contract or the contractors the
different businesses what did you have
to learn in order to be successful in in
creating this Marketplace
it's a great question getting a
Marketplace going in any vertical or use
case is really really challenging
because you know if you're just building
a SAS product it's kind of like being a
construction worker you you've got a set
of specs and you and you just build it
you try to listen to your users and you
and you try to make it better and you
you ship it and you deliver it and you
charge for it uh building a Marketplace
is less like a being a construction
worker and more like being a gardener
kind of like you know experiment over
here work the soil over here uh try to
try to get something growing over here
and just kind of observe what happens
and so the feedback loop takes a lot a
lot longer and like you'll make
decisions today that that won't show
results for like six months until you
figure what really happened but because
you're you're orchestrating this this uh
dynamic between buyers and sellers and
you're trying to figure out how to
deliver a Marketplace a way for them to
do business before uh that that's ten
times easier than they could could
beforehand and it really does have to be
10 times easier I get a lot of Founders
that ask me advice about marketplaces
and how to build them and and it's like
yeah okay that would be nice if you
could push a button and hire a uh a
painter for your home but is it really
ten times better than just going on Yelp
and finding somebody and calling them I
don't know and so it's like you really
have to deliver something that is a lot
smoother faster quicker cheaper simpler
than the status quo and a lot of times
the the wants and needs of both sides of
that transaction are at odds with each
other and so you're kind of this Arbiter
of of what's fair and uh it's it's
challenging it's basically I go from
failure to failure uh experimenting
without a loss of enthusiasm so that's
one reason why it took us a decade to
get this this company going
and ultimately what were some of the
consumer behaviors that you've
identified as you know insights for
for yours for your own success that
you've sort of
oh you know that you that you really
narrowed it down to that that made the
big debate the big difference or the big
leap year yeah when you when you start a
business like this you have all these
assumptions and you have all of these uh
things you think are true until until uh
you get the product into the marketplace
and and you start listening to people
using it and so we were wrong about a
lot of things one uh one thing we were
wrong about was we believed we were
delivering a uh a luxury Service uh uh
uh uh kind of like uber in the in the
early days with the with their black
cars and we believe that our strategy
would be to go high-end and then work
our way down and and so we started
realizing real quick that that the
people that spend you know three four
five thousand dollars a year with their
Landscape Maintenance don't really need
an app like greenpal because their their
vendor is giving them white glove
service already what we learned really
quick was it was the lower end Market it
was the people that just wanted a lawn
mowing every two weeks for 30 bucks that
nobody was returning their phone calls
they were getting flaked on they were
getting ghosted uh nobody really wanted
to work with them that was the consumer
demand that we were able to make it as
easy as just ordering a pizza off a
Domino's app or something you know as
easy as easy as ordering an Uber and
whereas a status quo is you leave 10
voicemails for 10 different contractors
maybe two might call you back one might
give you an estimate says you'll be
there Thursday he doesn't show up like
that's the typical uh customer
experience for trying to get this chore
done well with green power all these pop
their address in push a button and it
just happens like magic and so tackling
uh that lower end
um you know a thousand dollars a year
customers is is where we where we found
that we had a strong value proposition
so that was one of the key insights
really early on like in the first year
that we didn't know until we started
talking to our customers and
experimenting with who we were marketing
to
and what's it like running for for 10
years on something like this so you have
this idea that this idea change
dramatically over these 10 years or did
did you what what did change
significantly over these last 10 years
yeah you know the eye is funny I didn't
know the first thing about starting a
technology product a decade ago when I
sold my landscaping business but it's
remarkable how the idea is exactly the
same as it was back then it's hey wow
grass is three feet tall I can't get
anybody to mow it I should be able to
push a button and get it done and then
on the contractor side it's I've got 300
of these people uh on my books I don't
know when I'm supposed to be where I'm
not getting paid quick enough this is
organized chaos I hate running this
business I need a simpler way of doing
it and so that's the value proposition
for contractors and so it's like they
they now all of their stuff all of their
all of their customers is in the palm of
their hand they get paid within 24 hours
they know where they're supposed to be
every day all of it's organized in in
terms of the fastest route possible so
it's like one clean place for them to do
business and not have all of the
headache and Chaos of of trying to to
Wrangle one of these uh types of
services together and so and so that was
like in the early days that was the idea
and it's still the same idea today we're
still figuring out how do we make it
cheaper faster smoother more reliable
for for consumers and then for
contractors how do we make it to where
they can make more money more profit
with less headache and less effort and
and still working on that same problem
for a decade so that's the same things
that were different
um you know learning about what makes
people say yes what what is it really
that the consumer is looking for and and
in the early days we thought well we
want to give them a way to save money on
lawn mowing services because they'll get
they'll get five competitive bids and
they can save money and uh what we came
to learn was people really didn't care
about saving five bucks they just wanted
the guy to show up on Wednesday when he
was supposed to show up that's it like
making sure it was consistent and
reliable is is this is the value
proposition and not necessarily saving a
few bucks on the service that was
something that that changed really uh in
the year two or three we in the way we
marketed the services from the cheapest
way to get your grass cut in in Houston
Texas to uh no don't now you don't have
to worry about the The Disappearing lawn
guy anymore higher hire a reliable
landscaper with a touch of a button you
know that framing how we make somebody's
life better did change and evolve as we
learned what problems we were solving in
the world
that's really interesting
how how do you still think 10 years
um and go on this journey and stay
motivated and stay humble and
and I'll rigorously tackle this how do
you how do you keep that mentality for
10 10 years is a long time
and yours is a very long time you know
for for me
but one one key thing I did uh in you
know starting this business was I made a
decision that no matter what I was going
to be working on my best idea and that
was just it so that helps a lot in the
first two or three years when we had no
progress like it was just really
grueling and there was many many days
weeks months where I wanted to give up
but the default was well I'm just going
to be working on my best idea greenpal
is my best idea I have no other better
ideas let's just keep working on that
and so that default kind of mentality
really kind of enabled my team and I to
Slug It Out the first three or four
years there was also a lot in those
first three four years there was a lot
of learning uh that we had to do we had
to learn how to build software learn how
to architect a Marketplace learn how to
do things like SEO to get customers and
stuff like that and so so that took a
long time you know if I had known all
that stuff I probably could shave three
or four years off of this journey but I
had to learn it and there was no
shortcut to do that just had to do it I
had to learn and so the other so the
other thing that that I've done I guess
over the last decade to stay motivated
is is just and to celebrate the
Milestones so when we uh in our first
year we wanted to do a hundred customers
a week and we ended with 50. and that's
our second year we we got to like 120
customers
um and and now you know we do we do tens
of thousands of transactions a day but
we set up we set out little milestones
and when we hit them we really celebrate
them like like like like it's like you
know like it's the best thing that ever
happened to us so that makes it fun
um and and just breaking that down into
into goals and then and then looking at
the systems to get there that's how
we've that's how we've done it the other
thing is is
um there's a quote that uh that that
when you're starting a business the
years are short and the days are long
and that's how it's been for for me you
know this decade's gone by so quick now
there's been a lot of grind in there but
it goes by it goes by fast you know and
I usually tell folks there are no
overnight successes it's going to take
you five to seven years to figure
something out so just just get your best
idea and then work keep working on it
right so if you're looking today at
entrepreneurs that are looking that are
starting their Journeys or they're in
year one or two of their of their long
journey uh what what
what question would you ask them
to see if this is the right Journey for
them because they it's not a trivial
quest to go on if it's if it's in the
early early early stages where I think a
lot a lot of folks just kind of meander
lost in the desert
they do and I've been guilty of this
they do everything
but get a customer to put a credit card
number in and pay for something you know
they what's the social media strategy
what's the brand strategy let's keep
working on the website let's let's uh
let's do everything but get 10 customers
and it's like no just get 10 customers
you know like figure out if you can get
10 people to pay for this thing and just
hand crank everything else and then and
then uh and then learn to figure out if
you're solving a problem or not that can
save you two or three years of your life
I'll give you a quick story I had a guy
uh talk to me the other day he's like
hey I want to build a Marketplace uh I
have this idea I just built a a new home
and I went to the back of a lumber yard
and I got I found out all of these like
spare uh pieces of dead inventory that
they had and I was able to save
thousands of dollars with this window
here and this door here and this
countertop here and so my theory is is
that all of these supply houses have all
of this dead inventory and there should
be a marketplace where you should be
able to order this stuff like off the
shelf I'm like man that's a great idea
like yeah so I'm building the
marketplace I'm building the app I'm
Bill he's a coder I'm building all this
stuff and I'm like hold on a second
do me a favor go to that that Supply
yard just say hey I want to sit in the
back office for a week and I want to
sell all this crap you've got and I'll
sell you know and and whatever it is you
can you can keep 90 of it and see if you
can sell that crap on eBay offer up
Facebook Marketplace Craigslist whatever
just sell it manually he's like why why
should I do that it's like you're going
to understand a lot about this business
just by doing that for two or three days
he's like okay
by the end of the second day he calls me
said there's no business here so
so
he was going to spend a year building
out like the whole back-end system the
inventory system the consumer facing
ordering system you know how he was
gonna he was gonna spend building all
this stuff six months maybe two years
but it was like two in two days he was
able to figure out no there's not
there's no opportunity here so that's
that's that's the advice I would bestow
upon all first-time Founders and really
anybody starting with a new idea from
scratch just try to distill it down to
the simplest pieces and hand crank it
and then figure out if there's a
business there then build the technology
wow fantastic brand I really want to
thank you for coming here this is such
an enjoyable episode uh really a amazing
journey 10-year overnight success lots
of great insights and uh and and just a
very cool story overall so thank you
very very much for your time and your
energy and best of luck with uh with
with so many more Adventures that I'm
sure will come so thank you awesome
Michael thanks for having me on I
enjoyed it
thank you